bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
petit à petit et ça je trouve que c'est
olympe et n'ayant plus aucun but ou
tout cas j'espère que cela vous plaira
dans cette nouvelle vidéo la hype tort 4
des avengers est désormais révolu
c'est justement la réunification de 3
plutôt pertinent pour le mc eu car si
quand ça sortira d'ailleurs je devais
aventure actuellement et bien il n'y a
thor qui permettra d'empêcher le gode
marvel adapte ceci cela peut justifier
vous sortir une vidéo moon knight la
ensuite pour moi le deuxième axe
commence à pointer le bout de son nez
important serait l'avènement de jane
avec ce tout premier teaser et il ya
semaine dernière mais bon vu que j'étais
aucune raison de ne pas y participer et
butcher d'arriver à ses fins nous y
le fait que jane deviennent digne de
malade bah du coup j'ai pas pu donc on
foster en mighty thor effectivement
particularité étant donné que fally gars
retrouvons un tort adolescents letort
déjà des choses intéressantes à dire en
maniez mjöllnir d'ailleurs cet arc
va se rattraper cette semaine avec
c'est take away titi qui nous le dit lui
étaient réputés dans les comics comme un
vrai ce teaser est également un peu une
adultes et principal et enfin un vieux
l'épisode 4 et puis bah voilà n'hésitez
concorde aussi sur le fait que thor n'a
même le scénariste de tort à narok et du
excuse cela va me servir de prétexte
champion de tournois tort avec orgue
tort père de toute chose sachant qu'en
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne a laissé
pas vu jane depuis longtemps comme dans
pour enfin vous parlez de torts castres
coup pas de tort love and thunder tort
pourrait partir à la recherche de cette
les comics thor retrouverait jane qui
un commentaire il ya un petit pouce
plus avec la phase iv nous sommes dans
car on en a pas beaucoup parlé sur la
vieille connaissance pour le tournoi
quatre nous contera une grande histoire
bleus s'étaient argot rock que le line
est malade et qui aurait refait sa vie
la thématique du multivers voilà bon en
chaîne encore hormis la théorie de gore
mais se rendrait compte que ce dernier
d'amour et justement ce n'est pas pour
mais aussi darcis a réapparu ce solo
tout cas c'était peut-être simplement
rares soit avec vous allez ciao tout le
est mort et donc qu'une menace arrive
le boucher des dieux je vous avais
une référence mais je trouvais que
rien qu'il y as love dans le titre thor
proposé donc écouter let's go ne tardons
monde 2
dans one la vision alors qu'avec jane
bon sa part loin mais voilà c'est une
c'était intéressant a mentionné
et jane vont se retrouver dans thor 4 et
elle était normalement inséparables cela
pas plus longtemps n'hésitez pas à vous
concernant gore également il y a un plan
idée comme ça en tout cas je pense
peut traduire un changement dans le
personnellement que zeus pourraient
abonner à l'est que la vidéo commence
leur histoire d'amour a de grande chance
très précis dans le teaser qui fait
personnage bref je suis curieux de voir
mourir de la main de gore dieu est un
tout d'abord j'aimerais commencer en
de renaître néanmoins comme vous le
référence aux comics de thor god of
l'évolution de jane foster en revanche
savez les films marvel sont basés sur
vous disant que pour moi tort love and
thunder c'est celui ci c'est énorme
dieu majeur ce n'est pas n'importe qui
les comics même s'il ya toujours une
je vous avoue que je n'ai pas
thunder aura trois axes principaux et je
entité est en fait un dieu un dieu qui a
et avec le teaser nous comprenons qu'il
spécialement de réponse quant à la
certaine réécriture on retrouve toujours
refabrication de mjolnir et je pense que
trouve que c'est important d'en parler
aura une place assez importante dans le
pour nom fall égard le béhémoth sa mort
des aspects importants de l'histoire des
effectivement il faut tout d'abord que
film le faire mourir de la main de gore
le mcs sera libre concernant cette
comics et c'est là que cela peut devenir
le film répondent à la fin des ventures
n'est pas anodine car il a en fait été
serait un moyen de marquer au fer rouge
interprétation dans les comics mjolnir a
intéressant s'il ya une chose qui est
endgame la phase 4 de marvel a bien
tués par goor pendant sa quête et
l'esprit des autres dieux et nous ferait
sûre c'est que thor love and thunder
déjà été brisée a été re forgé par le
surtout son assassinat est un message
redémarré depuis avengers 4 mais nous
comprendre à quel point gore et puissant
sera beaucoup basé sur la saga de thor
dieu tempête une sorte de dieu est né
très fort car fally gars est un dieu
n'avons toujours pas de réponse quant à
enfin concernant les gardiens de la
god of thunder publié vers 2012 déjà car
sous forme d'orages cosmique bref un
la suite des aventures de thor et
très puissant capable de manier les
galaxie je pense qu'ils auront un rôle
truc qui est peut-être un peu trop
surtout comment il a géré mentalement la
trous noirs et c'est en plus un champion
ambigu pour un film du mc eu donc je
mineur dans le film thor love and
oui ce sont les comics qui introduisent
du tournoi des immortels donc cela
bataille contre thanos dans une finition
gore le boucher des dieux on va y
thunder a beaucoup à nous raconter avec
pense que marvel nous trouvera une autre
prouve la menace que symbolise gore le
revenir mais c'est également
noire tort a tout perdu en échouant face
explication étant donné que les débris
l'introduction à une situation
l'intégration d'autres dieux l'avènement
boucher des dieux et or semblent s'en
se trouve normalement là où news garde a
à la noce le protagoniste prend très à
particulière que jane doit faire face et
de jane foster en mighty thor ou encore
rendre compte d'ailleurs lassus
été fondé peut-être que valkyrie ou
semblerait qu'il y ait moyens de faire
coeur son rôle de dieu du tonnerre et de
où après elle deviendra la mighty thor
l'arrivée de gore le boucher des dieux
une petite théorie vous l'avez vu dans
quelqu'un vivant à new age garde aurait
futur roi d'asgard et c'est quelque
avec son origin story le teaser nous
le trailer c'est également
dans cette saga jane est malheureusement
trouvé une solution pour reforger
l'introduction du dieu zeus dans le
chose qui lui met une pression monstre
montre qu'il se sépare des gardiens et
atteinte d'un cancer qui la consume
mjolnir bref tout est possible enfin le
marvel cinématiques universe et il sera
surtout en sachant que c'est un titre
ce n'est pas pour rien il a déjà son
petit à petit et cela se déroule
troisième axe qui pour moi est important
histoire à faire et toute façon les
une condition qu'il n'a finalement pas
incarné par russell crowe zeiss est
d'ailleurs pendant que thor affronte
et bien évidemment l'arrivée de gore le
gardiens auront leur troisième film donc
également le leader d'olympe et thor
spécialement désiré et c'est via ngame
gore le boucher des dieux thor va
boucher des dieux même s'il antagonistes
ainsi que korg semble s'y retrouver sauf
voilà
finalement l'apprendre découvrira
que l' on le comprend véritablement même
et absent du teaser il y a quand même
écoutez je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là
qu'elle a également refait sa vie depuis
s'il est un dieu thor reste au fond un
que pourquoi irait-il à olympe et bien
et voudra à tout prix lui venir en aide
des petites choses intéressantes à dire
j'espère sincèrement que la vidéo vous
homme et un homme qui n'a pas encore
un seul axe est intéressant il
déjà le tout premier plan du trailer
chose qu'elle refusera gentiment la
aura plu je suis désolé d'avoir sorti
semblerait qu'un événement particulier
véritablement trouvé sa voie les
n'est pas anodin pour moi nous y voyons
se déroule à olympe nous voyons des
peu de vidéos récemment j'étais malade
suite je ne pense pas qu'elle sera
premiers plans du trailer sont pour moi
réadapté car dans les comics mjolnir
sortes de feu d'artifice enfin bref des
à tort enfants courir puis un tort
de fous je sais pas si ça sent encore là
très parlant car tort de la même manière
n'est pas brisé comme dans le mc eu en
adolescents et enfin un corps adulte
éléments qui nous font penser à un
je parle un peu du nez et surtout je
que thanos quand il était au jardin
spectacle puis nous voyons de ce brandir
fait pour faire simple thor va perdre le
suis en train de préparer en ce moment
déjà cela traduit pour moi le fait que
après avoir réussi sa mission se repose
un gros concept que j'aimerais sortir
son éclair et se faire acclamer par la
contrôle de mjolnir qui sera laissé à
thor devra explorer sont passés dans le
sur la chaîne une nouvelle série de
et déposent les armes on retrouve
l'abandon sur la lune et jane sera
film effectivement gore étant un boucher
foule est ce qu'au final il n'y aurait
vidéos on va dire sur le thème de marvel
pas une sorte de tournoi qui est en
stormbreaker plantées au sol tout comme
appelée télépathiquement par le marteau
des dieux en quête de vengeance tort en
train de se dérouler sur olympe
et l'emploi n'y aura plus tard la
thanos avait déposé son armure et il
j'ai vraiment envie d'évoluer et
tant que fils d'odin et d'une longue
effectivement dans les comics il y à des
faisant devenir mighty thor mais bon
d'avancer et du coup bah tout ça demande
lignée devra répondre des actes de ses
regarde l'horizon comme son plus grand
événements de ce type par moments par
pour une réadaptation pour le mc hugh je
ennemi pour moi l'écho est très fort car
du temps et notamment de la réflexion en
aïeuls les dieux dans marvel ne sont pas
exemple nous avons le tournoi des
pense qu'il ya de grandes chances que
on retrouve la dualité qu'il avait avec
parfaits et rien qu'au d'un en compagnie
nous retrouvions les bases de thor god
champions qui oppose les plus grands
le titan foot or avec ngame a finalement
guerriers das garde au travers de
dé la ont mené d'innombrables guerre et
of thunder car le cancer de jane traduit
plusieurs jeux ce sont des sortes de
ont causé beaucoup de souffrances tort
réussi sa mission la moitié de l'univers
jeux olympiques en groupe bourré je vais
une évolution du personnage c'est
devra répondre à tout ça néanmoins ce
a été ramenée thanos est mort les
vraiment un élément important jane va
faire un peu le gars lourd mais bon dans
plan évoque également autre chose
olympique il y à olympie bref tout ça
avengers ont été en quelque sorte
changer effectivement ce que je trouve
d'intéressant je trouve et cela se passe
dissous c'est une nouvelle page qui
intéressant avec cet arc c'est qu'avec
pour dire que thor en tant que dieu
s'écrit désormais pour le dieu du
toujours dans les comics de thor god of
la maladie sachant qu'elle peut mourir à
seraient conviés à participer à ce
tonnerre son air héroïque en compagnie
thunder lors de la quête de vengeance de
cause du cancer jane va souhaiter faire
tournoi des dieux organisé par zeus sur
gore ce dernier souhaitera dans l'acte
le bien autour d'elle au final elle peut
final créer une bombe qui anéantira tous
même être prêt à mourir pour les autres
car de toute façon le insert la consume
les du à travers le temps et l'espace et
[Musique]